Antarctica has just had its hottest day
ever recorded the temperature rules to
18 point 3 degrees Celsius that was at
an Argentine research base it's on the
Antarctic Peninsula jutting up towards
South America and that part of the
continent has warmed much faster than
the global average over the past 50
years causing glaciers to shrink by 87
percent the scientists fear global
warming will eventually disintegrate the
ice sheet across the entire South Pole
and that's will cause sea levels
worldwide to rise by at least 3 metres
well Andrew Sheppard's is a professor of
Earth Observation at the University of
Leeds he researches the changes in the
Antarctic and its impact on the
environment he joins us now on skype
from Leeds good to have you with us here
on al-jazeera
and first of all just how alarming is
this development it's really important
this temperature record from the
Argentine base has been really powerful
for us it's allowed us to say whether
the changes that are happening in
Antarctica in this part of the continent
short-term fluctuations or a long-term
trend and it's definitely the latter but
they also very much like the Canadian
fires at the moment give us a glimpse
into the future and how different parts
of the world will be in just a few
decades time and are we just talking a
matter of years a matter of decades no I
mean or do you think this is this is
reversible in some way so we've learned
a lot about how ice responds to changes
in climate just because of this
particular part of the planet the
northern tip of the Antarctic Peninsula
there are a series of ice shelves and
they're really floating extensions of
glass tears into the sea and they've
broken away over the past two or three
decades and we didn't think that that
was possible until it started to happen
and that's an irreversible process they
won't grow back again for a thousand
years and this is the first time it's
happened
in 10,000 years so this is definitely a
signal of dramatic change happening in
our lifetimes just talk us through the
significance of this particular region
in the Antarctic what why is this region
such a focus of research and development
well it's it's definitely the most
easily accessible so this this part of
Antarctica is that the similar latitude
to Iceland in the northern hemisphere
and that's why it gets warm in summer
but just three or four decades ago it
was a cold place and it had lots of ice
and now that Isis has gone and and and
the ice is retreating for the South in
Antarctica but we learned how really
glasses respond to ocean and upstraight
warming because of what's happened here
and we can use that information to
improve our predictions of what's going
to happen farther south where there's a
lot more ice and in terms of these
predictions like certainly would you say
these are melting faster than was
anticipated we've heard from the various
cop summits that the average temperature
rises is escalating it's going faster
and faster and faster is this in your
opinion is this running out of control
or is there still time to try and rein
in this process of climate change so
there's always time to reduce the
effects that might happen in the future
when there are a very hot planet we can
do things to reverse what's happening
today in some instances but it's it's
not realistic to expect our planet to
cool even if we all reduce our emissions
to Net Zero as people hope will happen
in in two or three decades time that's
not going to cool the planet again and
so we're already committed to some
sea-level rise and that's where we also
need governments and people to be
prepared for what's going to be
happening in coastal parts of many
countries by the end of this century
people will experience flooding more
frequently to today okay Andrew
scheffers great to get your thoughts and
your analysis thank you so much for
speaking to us here
aljazeera thank you